today we're going to be speaking with
democratic congressman raja
krishnamurthy who represents the 8th
district of illinois that's the western
chicago suburbs he's chairman of the
house oversight committee on economic
and consumer policy also a member of the
very important house intelligence
committee congressman it's great to have
you on today
hey thank you so much david same here
so okay i mean to start we we spoke
today about for the first time in his
presidency in the real clear politics
average joe biden's approval has dipped
just slightly below 40 it's not great
it's lower than at this point even where
donald trump was at this point in his
presidency and that was not good
i attribute this to sort of a lull in
what we might call
major accomplishments to point to
what do you think is driving these
numbers and what would you like to see
the biden administration do
well i think that
covid
inflation
and
probably the lack of
progress on certain initiatives in
congress contribute to this
but obviously
as you know
elections are brought choices
and i think that
we're going to have some stark choices
in the fall
and but before then we absolutely have
to do better in congress but also
hopefully we can see covid
decline and inflation come under some
control
do you uh as an individual who's up for
re-election every every two years
do you worry when the president's
approval is low that it will affect your
re-election
well i think that
the president's standing
definitely affects
uh
how different elected officials and
democrats
kind of fair because of the environment
that the president's standing will
influence
but i think at the end of the day um you
know voters also try to balance
local concerns and how they perceive
their local elected officials
performance based on their own
experiences for instance
to assess uh you know whether to support
that person
and so i think the same will be true in
this election all that being said uh we
need to make sure that the president's
successful when he's successful
everyone's successful
but to do that we have to make sure that
we deliver for the american people and
address their uh you know everyday
concerns right now
when it comes to something like the the
russia ukraine situation i mean i think
that
bad faith actors will criticize
uh the president and democrats no matter
what is done either as being weak or or
too uh
strong or not being friendly enough or
you know whatever the case may be bad
faith actors will have their criticisms
but
what would you like to see uh the the
the role of the biden administration in
the united states on the basis of what
happens there in the next few months
well actually i think that the
administration has done a tremendous job
of pulling together our allies onto the
same page with regard to
aggression on ukrainian
ukrainian borders
i think that
[Music]
what we need to see at this point is
more multilateral
coordination with regard to
what the costs russia would face were to
invade ukraine and that means agreeing
on a very
strong sanctions regime
agreeing on what we would do to support
ukraine if it is invaded
and of course
you know what do we do to give russia an
off-ramp uh with regard to the current
crisis
if we can do those three things
energetically and in a coordinated
fashion
i think that uh hopefully we'll get to a
better place but right now obviously is
a very dangerous moment
what what does your gut tell you and you
know you're on the house intelligence
committee but so so your gut and what
intelligence you've been presented there
may be some some gray area there but
what does your gut tell you about the
the real objective here of putin is this
to to suss out how people will will
react without a real plan to invade
it's very interesting and and um i had
the privilege of um
attending a classified briefing with
uh cia director bill burns who's a a
tremendous public servant by the way uh
we had this uh two-hour conversation on
monday
and without getting into classified
details i think that what i can say for
sure is that
uh putin has a very emotional connection
to
uh ukraine in the sense that it's almost
like a maniacal obsession with making
sure ukraine does not further
um kind of drift into the western orbit
interestingly all of his actions since
2014 the invasion of crimea
uh the
the presence of
russians and the don bass have further
uh pushed ukrainians into
the the embrace of western countries
the second observation i have is that um
i do think that
uh putin if he's just operating as a
rational actor and setting aside his
maniacal
kind of personal obsession with ukraine
knows that
all things being equal
he doesn't want to have a situation
where he invades and then has another
afghanistan on his hands just as the
soviet union did
30 years ago
and i think that
because of that
i do think that there will be a search
for
diplomatic options that allow him to
save face
even at the same time that he you know
kind of rattles the sabers
my hope is that his head prevails over
his heart
um and that we can kind of
uh
convince or persuade him that the cost
would just be prohibitive for him and
you know at the end of the day
he might
want to have on his tombstone that he
was the one who joined ukraine to russia
but the alternative could just as be
could be just as plausible which is he's
the one that lost ukraine
and so i think that's kind of the the
balance right now
is there uh
discussion amongst your colleagues about
the possibility that
in the the sort of using the ukraine
russia situation as cover that china may
see an opportunity to escalate
aggression with taiwan is that a topic
of consideration
it is um
i think there's
two reasons why potentially
she may not the the chinese premier xi
jinping may not move on taiwan right now
which is uh a i don't think that
uh china is prepared militarily to
invade taiwan and i my perception is
that
they don't think that they have
enough of a military advantage
over the united states in that region
that's my perception that's how i feel
and then the second is he himself is
trying to consolidate political power
this year
in china with the
i believe it's the chinese people's
congress that's happening in september
or october
and so he's also focused on making sure
that he can uh bring all the elites
along to basically um
rubber stamp
his uh
being in office
for longer than perhaps any other
premiere in many years
um a couple of other things and there's
really so much to talk about in terms of
inflation
um
similarly to gas prices where certainly
a president can do a little bit on some
of these issues but really these are big
structural systemic things that are
often global in nature
what can be done about inflation what
should be done about inflation
well i think it's a real issue and you
you don't have to go further than your
grocery store or your gas pump to see
that it's a real issue and anybody who
doesn't think so is denying reality
i think there are three things that
we as lawmakers and the buying
administration can do to tackle this
first is we have to fight covid
and we have to make sure that
we see
a decline in cases here but also abroad
so david in that regard i'm going to put
in a big plug for my legislation and my
moves to really get the world vaccinated
at this point not just the united states
because if we see variant after variant
come from abroad including the delta
variant which killed three of my distant
relatives in india and then the omicron
variant and others come to our shores
it's going to wreak more havoc work with
our economy and lead to more inflation
so that's the first thing we have to
control covid here and abroad the second
thing we have to do
is
you know those infrastructure
investments which we approved in the
fall
have to be directed at short-term
logistical bottlenecks
that
kind of continue to hamper the supply
chain so just as an example um we should
direct as much of that money as possible
in the short term to modernizing our
ports uh to making sure that our rail
facilities uh are modern and
capable of handling the surge in goods
that's happened now
um having pop-up inland ports and so
forth the third thing that we have to do
is we have to we have to um
call a spade a spade and
note that some companies are engaging in
predatory pricing practices
and on my committee the house oversight
subcommittee on economic and consumer
policy which is a mouthful we launched
an investigation into the meat
processing industry which
where four firms control more than 60
percent of meat processing and have
increased prices
double digits year after year and are
seeing net profits go through the roof
and we and that the same thing is
happening in other industries and so if
we do do those three things i think it
starts to help
but really what we need to do is make
sure that we can uh take the disruptions
out of the supply chain that will be the
biggest
help at this point
on uh to pick a couple of those things i
mean on vaccinating the world when you
look at a world map right now
we're basically talking about africa
where there's the serious lack of
vaccines i mean even if you know you
look at south america there's you know
in eastern europe there's still fewer
vaccine doses but but availability is
increasing rapidly
really everywhere but africa as far as i
understand looking at the map so is that
the area that should be the focus
i think that has to be uh among the top
places that we direct our efforts you
know in africa
it's still i think uh under 20
of the continent of 1.2 billion people
are vaccinated
and
i bet you you know dollars to donuts
that the next variant if it emerges is
going to be from a place like africa
and what we fear is that the lethality
of the next variant could far exceed
omicron and still have its
contagiousness
and that's what we have to be really
worried about and i i i'm concerned that
we have a real blind spot here david to
this issue and that's why i and jeff
merkley and others are pushing very hard
for the white house to direct more funds
much more funds in this direction
because it's a real ma really a modest
investment compared to the
price that we've paid to repair our
economy and our health care system in
other ways
so what about domestically at this point
i mean i i have a feeling that due to
political reasons
sometime between now and the state of
the union on march 1st the white house
will likely do some sort of a pseudo
mission accomplished type transition to
the endemic phase statement and whether
that's uh
medically prudent is a question that
remains to be seen but you know in
illinois jb pritzker has said it's going
to be time to start winding down
mass requirements we're seeing it happen
in california new york some places in
schools does that make sense to you
right now based on the data what are the
milestones we should be looking at
otherwise
um is an important question
i think that
to some degree it makes sense to wind
down some of these mandates because at
the end of the day
we are seeing
a rapid decline in covid cases
and
i think there's a lot of public pressure
as well to
start to wind down some of those
mandates however we have to be prudent
about that because especially in schools
and other places where a lot of people
are yet to be vaccinated or ineligible
to be vaccinated
we just have to be cautious
and so um
i think that
striking that balance is extremely
important right now
but i think that at the end of the day
we have to stick to the science david we
can't just
wish this pandemic away we're going to
have to be very cautious because look we
all want to keep the schools open we all
want to keep businesses open we want the
economy to stay open and we cannot ever
go into lockdown so to prevent that we
have to take these very
basic precautions such as mass wearing
masks distancing and so forth
okay uh last thing i want to talk about
nancy pelosi in december said no to a
congressional stock trading ban
in january she said she's open to it and
now she's actually supporting it can you
talk a little bit about your thoughts on
the issue but also
the specifics of how such a ban might
work in the sense that a ban on making
trades of individual stocks while in
office is a very sort of narrow thing
and how this applies to significant
others or family members how this
applies to mutual funds and other things
i mean what would you like to see what
makes sense
i think what i'd like to see is my bill
become law it's the ban conflicted
trading act is the main
bill that's being discussed right now
it has bicameral bipartisan support
which is unusual for anything these days
in congress
and it's i think the subject of
negotiations at this point basically
what it would do is this david which is
what we know is that the stock act does
not work
that is the act which basically requires
disclosures
of
trading of individual stocks and
securities but doesn't prohibit it
what we found is that according to a
recent report 54 members of congress
violated just those disclosure
requirements
but hundreds of others followed those
requirements but have created a
tremendous appearance
of insider trading uh you know basically
people assume that when members of
congress pull out their ameritrade app
and start trading stocks that they're
doing so based on non-public information
they gain from classified briefings and
hearings and insight into legislation so
the consensus in the grassroots among
democrats and republicans is the current
system does not work
what my bill does
is the following it basically
bans or prevents or prohibits members
from trading individual stocks and
securities
allows them to remain invested and to
trade mutual funds and widely
diversified funds it also
if people wish to trade they can do so
through a blind trust if they wish to
keep their stocks they can but they
can't trade them they have to hold them
for the
the time that they're in office
and at the end of the day um what we're
trying to do david is
uh we're trying to restore a little bit
of trust back in congress here
and when every story comes out
saying that some member traded fi you
know bought pfizer stop because they got
word that pfizer just developed a
vaccine
or sold pfizer stock when they just got
word that the pandemic is um actually
receding
um that just creates the appearance that
they're trading on insider information
and it erodes trust further so we got to
bring this to an end now would this do
would there be anything in this bill
that would prevent
nancy pelosi from saying to her husband
okay you make these moves because this
is this is what's going on and would she
be in compliance in that situation
so uh
technically that would be a violation of
the stock act if she were to do that
but if this particular bill applies to
members and congressional staff i'm
definitely open to spouses being added
perhaps through an amendment to this
particular bill
right now i just want to see the bill
move
because i think we could sit here and
basically have a situation where nothing
gets done
because people want the perfect bill and
really right now what we want is a good
bill
and we need it fast and i'm really
pleased that the grassroots and public
pressure have brought us to this moment
along with mine and my colleagues
fierce advocacy in congress
but we need reforms right now david yep
we're going to be watching that uh that
that bill very very closely we've been
speaking with democratic congressman
raja krishnamurthy who represents the
8th district of illinois really
appreciate your time today
yes sir thanks so much for having me